in einer gondel die kanäle hinabgleiten
selbst für den erfahrenen gondoliere
maurizio karl-otto immer noch ein
romantisches erlebnis
natürlich sind frauen die beste
kundschaft obwohl ich noch nicht sagen
sollte ganz gleich welcher nationalität
er ist einer von venedig rund 600
normalerweise macht karl otto drei toren
am tag aber seit beginn der pandemie ist
er praktisch arbeitslos
seit oktober habe ich eine einzige fahrt
gemacht
die stadt erwacht gerade aus dem letzten
loch
das weltberühmte café florian noch
bleibt es unter der woche geschlossen
vor der pandemie waren die straßen voll
mit touristen aus der ganzen welt
20 millionen besucher im jahren brachten
der stadt geld und veränderte sich
einige hoffen dass nach der pandemie ein
neuanfang folgt der aktivist david booth
hat mit seiner gruppe wessel.com diese
tafel installiert
er zeigt den bevölkerungsschwund der
stadt
50 1965 ist die aktuelle zahl der
menschen die heute in venedig leben das
sind 30 leute weniger als in der woche
davor
der massentourismus treibt die bewohner
aus der stadt aber das problem liegt
venedig selbst leidet darunter dass der
mangel an touristen für viele menschen
einen mangel an arbeit bedeutet das
erleben wir jetzt gerade
wissen sie es ist eine merkwürdige
situation
wir wollen nicht zu viel tourismus bei
der den ort und stecken würde
gleichzeitig können wir ohne tourismus
nicht geben
dort wo jeder auf die ein oder andere
weise vom tourismus lebt ist es
schwierig eine balance zu finden
der tourismusbeauftragte der stadt
erzählt uns die situation sei nicht
einzigartig für venedig wohl benötige
venedig aber eine einzigartige lösung in
venedig hat kein ausverkauf
stattgefunden alle beliebten touristen
stellte kam in den letzten jahren erlebt
dass klare regeln fehlen sie teile der
stadt zu schützen
[Musik]
es wäre nötig stunde gesetze einzuführen
versteht ihr die venedig und florenz und
für ein ausgewogenes verhältnis von
touristen und bewohner als einen ersten
schritt hat die stadt damit begonnen die
besucherzahlen genauer zu verfolgt im
nächsten jahr wird die touristen eine
eintrittsgebühr gericht
noch nie zu karl otto hingegen vermisst
was manche die schlechte alte zeit auch
dahin zurückgehen hieß vor zwei jahren
mit ein paar leuten weniger aber es war
kein massaker wie sie immer sagen
die debatte darüber wie die zukunft des
tourismus in der stadt aussehen wird ist
noch lange nicht zu ende geführt aber
jetzt freuen sich venedig erstmal wieder
auf besucher